The following graph represents
the first five terms
of two given patterns.
In the answer box, there
are different statements
about the two patterns.
Choose all correct statements.
So here, for each point,
this point right over here,
this represents its
horizontal coordinate
is the first term of
pattern A, which is 4.
And its vertical coordinate
is the first term
in pattern B, which is 1.
And then we could do that
for the other points as well.
So actually, let's figure
out what the values are.
So we have pattern A and
then we have pattern B.
So the first term
for pattern A is 4.
And when pattern A is 4, the
first term for pattern B is 1.
The second term
for pattern A is 7.
And when pattern A is
7, pattern B is also 7.
Third term, pattern A is
10, and pattern B is 13.
And then the fourth
term, pattern A is 13,
and pattern B is 19.
And then finally, fifth
term, pattern A is 16,
and pattern B is 25.
Now, before even
looking at these,
let's see what we can think
about these patterns here.
So it looks like
pattern A starts at 4,
and it increases
by 3 every time.
To go from one term to the
next, you just have to add 3.
Now, what about for pattern B?
Well pattern B starts at
1, and every term here it
looks like you're adding 6.
So when pattern A
increases by 3 and we're
moving in the horizontal
direction based on the fact
that pattern A is represented
on the horizontal axis,
we're going to move up
6 in the vertical axis,
and we see that here.
Pattern A increases by 3
from one term to the next.
And when that increased
by 3, pattern B
increased by 6 from
one term to the next.
And we see that it
keeps doing that.
Now, let's think about
what we have over here
to see which of these statements
actually apply to this.
For every term in pattern
A, multiply the term by 2
and then subtract 7 to get the
corresponding term from pattern
B. So let's see
if that holds up.
So according to this,
if this was true,
I should be able to take
this, multiply it by 2
and subtract 7 and get that.
So let's see.
Is 1 equal to 2 times 8 minus 7?
Sorry, 2 times 4 minus 7.
So 2 times this number,
2 times 4 minus 7.
Well, 8 minus 7 is equal to 1.
Is this right over here equal
to 2 times this 7 minus 7?
Well, yeah, it's equal to 7.
Is 13 equal to 2
times 10 minus 7?
Well, yeah, 20 minus 7 is 13.
Is 19 equal to 2
times 13 minus 7?
26 minus 7 is 19.
Is 25 equal to 2
times 16 minus 7?
Well, 32 minus 7 is 25.
So this first
statement checks out.
For the corresponding term,
the value of pattern B
is two times the value
of pattern A minus 7.
Now let's look at
the second one.
The terms of
pattern B are always
greater than or equal to
their corresponding terms
from pattern A. Well,
no, that's not right.
It's true for a
couple of scenarios.
Here for the third,
fourth, and fifth term,
or actually for the second,
third, fourth, and fifth terms,
pattern B is equal to or
greater than pattern A.
But for the first
term, it's not true.
Pattern A is greater,
so this is not right.
To get from each
point to the next,
you need to move 3 units to
the right and 6 units up.
Well, that's exactly
what we talked about.
From one term to
the next, pattern A,
along our horizontal
axis, we increased by 3,
while pattern B, which is
plotted on our vertical axis,
by 6.
So you move 3 to
the right and 6 up.
So that is right.
The second terms of
both patterns are 7.
Well, yeah, we see
that right over here.
The second terms are 7.
We have 7 here, and
we have 7 there.
And so that is right as well.
So the only one that doesn't
apply is this second one.
This is not right.